there is no minimalist rulebook
well until now the minimalists have
created
16 rules for living with less
a free ebook which you can download
right now
at theminimalists.com resources enjoy
non-minimalists april wants to know
can you discuss your thoughts on
non-monogamy
can you discuss your thoughts on
non-monogamy this makes me the question
as i was reading this uh before i read
it out loud and i was reading it to
myself
can you discuss your judgment
on non-monogamy is how this question is
presented to me
oh because it's like well i mean
because it really like our thoughts is
like what's our judgment on
on non-monogamy yeah i mean i didn't
read it like that i read it as
uh how do you
i read it as as a a um do you
two as a couple um
believe it's good bad or indifferent for
a relationship but isn't that
that's a judgment though right yeah if i
was yeah if i was
making a judgment about someone else's
relationship for sure that would
definitely be a judgment oh
in terms of our relationship um
yeah you want to talk about this yeah
how far do you want to
go down the hall so oh god
you already started so you might as well
if you round up to six inches six inches
um in the first episode of how to love
we talk
about a concept called cleft
relationships
yeah i don't know we're not going to go
down that that hole
yeah we we could but it's a long answer
right i know
and and so i just wanted to put that out
there that like
yeah we go down there we go down this
this sort of non-monogamous ish
rabbit hole on that first episode of
huddle up right so if you're curious
about
a much more in-depth answer to this
question you can go there you'll never
guess what a cleft relationship is find
out in episode
how to love totally made-up word
yeah yeah and it's a made-up concept
that we we sort of came up with but i
will say this
to give you a summary in terms of
monogamous relationships
i think it ultimately comes down to
culture
right we've been acculturated
to believe a few things one is that
we must be monogamous
to another person if we want to be moral
if we and i don't i think that's
nonsense i i think there are plenty of
moral people who are not in a monogamous
relationship
aren't in a relationship at all and
there are immoral people who
are in a monogamous relationship right
and and so morality is
should not dictate uh whether or not
our um
should not dictate partners we have yeah
our
our
partnership preferences right and and so
i think the question around this is like
how do you define
monogamy how do you define cheating and
and all of these things
and i think those things need to be
defined
by the individuals who who come to the
table absolutely
we have a good friend ryan who has been
in several
non-monogamous polyamorous relationships
and he has found ways to thrive in in
those relationships right
but it does complect things by
definition
right so to complex is to add more than
one thing
to intertwine more than one thing
together well if you have three
strands that's more than two it is more
complex
you go beyond that and it becomes
infinitely more
complex yeah a piece of me wants to say
if if you don't find happiness with
yourself like it doesn't matter if
you're in a monogamous or non-monogamous
relationship which leads to
if you're in a monogamous relationship
you're going to think you're going to be
happier in a non-monogamous relationship
and then if you're in a non-monogamous
relationship at a certain point you're
going to be like maybe
maybe monogamy is what i want to do so
yeah that's often seeking out
the the thing you don't have right yeah
and then once you get
it's the same it's it's consumerism for
the soul
right and uh yeah that
that could be a good podcast title
consumerism i don't think it is for this
one but we maybe maybe in the future
um so it because it's or consumerism for
relationships in a way right it's
objective like that peter talks about
yes yeah and once it becomes once you
have that object a
it's it's what uh uh anthony demelo
talks about with
um when he works with priests they're
always talking about sex when he works
with prostitutes they're always talking
about god
it's it's because we perceive the thing
we don't have the object
a is going to be the thing that doesn't
just make us happy
but completes us yeah and and
that is the showing up empty or showing
up
half empty or whatever and expecting
to just be to have them pour their love
and acceptance and everything else
into me as though that is going to
complete me
but it's going to every relationship has
an us box
in the middle of it and we do give and
take the problem is when we start
treating it
like it's not tennis you know the the
tennis analogy were
a score of zero right you could take
something from that box but the score
has to remain at zero as soon as you
turn on the scoreboard
it's over for that us box it's over
game's over yeah
yeah so that's how i look at
non-monogamy i think
it's often appropriate for some people i
think it's
not appropriate for other people and i
think there are varying degrees of
monogamy and non-monogamy
as well and that's sort of what we
talked about with the cleft thing